the g7 summit was this past weekend as
you may have heard things quickly became
tense between President Trump and the
other leaders especially Canada's Justin
Trudeau that's right yeah
President Trump called Canada's leader
weak and dishonest things got very tense
now many of our closest allies are of
course quite unhappy about this one
person who's taking it particularly hard
is one of our shows only Canadian
writers Levi mcdougal all right
he asked to come out for a moment to
deliver a strongly worded statement to
President Trump on behalf of all
Canadians yeah I saw him on my way in
and he was you seething yeah no this is
the angriest I think I've ever seen him
it's something Levi feels he needs to
address
so please welcome our Canadian writer
Levi mcdougal Levi
[Applause]
thanks Conan President Trump you dropped
by my country's beautiful province of
Quebec for the g7 summit and insulted
the integrity of our honorable Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau
well we Canadians don't take kindly to
such blatant disrespect
so mr. Trump please listen closely to
what I'm about to say
hey don't okay Levi don't get worked up
there's no need if you get that angry
like I can't help it Conan the genies
out of the bottle you've crossed a line
mr. president and now I have no choice
but to draw another line just a little
bit further out from the first one and
if you cross that line - you better hope
I'm not out of chalk Levi take it down a
notch sorry Andy the notch ain't moving
mr. Trump your Washington Capitals just
won their first Stanley Cup and that's
great but the Montreal Canadiens have
won 24 Stanley Cup 24 I'm sorry I didn't
want to but you made me go there okay
Levi please just just watch your
language watch your mouth oh it's my
mouth that's the problem then I'll let
my hands do the talking fella
watch this Conan
hey Levi Levi he's the president that's
completely inappropriate well you know
what else was inappropriate mr. robert
de niro directed an expletive toward
president Trump at the Tony Awards
yesterday and I'm going to repeat that
message word-for-word right now bleep
Trump levite bleep isn't the word that
Trump our that De Niro actually used
what do you mean well the actual word he
used was that's a real word oh my god
Levi stated I'm sorry do we have do we
have a Canadian doctor in the house I'm
a Canadian doctor
come on buddy come on go here oh there
you go okay thanks here no problem me oh
so how much do I owe you
[Laughter]
that's enough we get security in here
let's get security okay boys time to go
okay okay sorry about this Conan just
remember it was your president who
unleashed the Beast hey how are you oh
good thanks Fran slow that's my doctor
hey nice to meet ya
[Applause]
come back a minute Pete is here we'll
see you tonight
you